[Music]
it's time for our scene and unseen
segment where we reveal the stories
behind the headlines
and for that we turn to author of the
forthcoming book the thief who stole
heaven fox news contributor raymond
arroyo all right ray
uh biden sent a pair of visiting angels
out to push his agenda today
laura it was all about emotionally
selling
that 1.9 trillion dollar covet package
we've been talking about
while kamala harris visited a small
business today
making the case that we need trillions
to help these entrepreneurs
never mind that only a pittance of the
money will go to them first lady
jill biden toured a pair of schools in
connecticut and pennsylvania
she was flanked by the new education
secretary and the teachers union leader
randy weingarten dr jill tried to engage
students and offer some advice
what are you reading
10 years from now we don't want to
forget what we learned about ourselves
and i think if we have a record of that
so i
encourage really all of you to to do
something
anything just to remember this time
laura why do children want to remember a
depressing time
when they regressed in learning or shut
their homes and kept from their friends
and for no good reason
remember the cdc guidance urged that
schools be reopened even without
teachers being vaccinated
but the biden administration and the
teachers unions didn't like that so
outwent the science
talk about neanderthal thinking and
randy weingarten whom you saw in one of
those clips was really
the shadow education secretary today
patrolling the language at these events
she doesn't want teachers back in school
until they get that 170
billion dollar payout from the coveted
relief bill
bad news uh leaning into the child and
saying
what are you reading i mean it's like
what are you wearing
okay the kids the kids are very
intimidated by all this star
power you know dr biden is in the hou
they're very intimidated so
i would have been awkward it would have
been great though raymond if they said
well dr
seuss all right ray where is biden by
the way
as a president he hasn't held a press
conference after
43 days in office something no president
in a hundred years has done
he's restricted to very tightly
controlled events like this bipartisan
cancer meeting in the oval today
the press was shoved out after a few
minutes and when biden does speak
he offers uh dresses here's what uh
i mean and uh
the vice president i are the view that
we can make significant strides
uh in fighting cancer and alzheimer's
and other diseases
uh if we uh take a slightly different
approach and
what i want to talk to them about today
is uh
how we go about uh
my god that's a new drinking game that's
a that's
right no we would all be loaded if it if
all was it was you know you could take a
shot on every uh
and aside from these empathetic events
when he conducts one of these zoom
meetings as he did today with democrats
about the covet bill
the white house is loathed to subject
biden to any questioning
who's pulling the court here laura
listen
and i'm happy to take questions if
that's what i'm supposed to do nance
whatever you want me to do
and it just they just bring the curtain
down on him laura
it's like biden is playing this hide
hide and go bleak
strategy here where the only times he
talks it's all this
emotive stuff about people dying or
family members dying and
how deeply he feels about it but then
otherwise the curtain comes down we get
no
questions but before i go i want your
reaction to the latest donation
to the smithsonian institution besides
edison's light bulb and judy garland's
ruby slippers
welcome dr fauci's 3d
covert model laura that's right anthony
fauci is receiving a great american
medal
from the smithsonian for his
extraordinary leadership during the
covet 19 pandemic
he donated his 3d model there laura i've
been waiting all day
your reaction to this new addition to
the smithsonian
horton hears a spike protein covert
spike protein
i mean that that looks that it looks
maybe a christmas ornament for next year
that'll be the white house
christmas ornament right there he should
he should donate he should have donated
the the report cards of the children
with all the f's and the business
foreclosures or better yet
donate himself behind glass he might be
a little less dangerous to everybody
under glass like
pheasant under glass so rhema thank you
so much